all right hello everyone this is women's
grandmaster sabina foyshore
thanks for joining san luis just club's
youtube channel
for today i have prepared some
interesting studies
that i'm looking forward to going over
with you guys
i hope you'll like them um
today's class is supposed to be called
insane in the end games
and we tried to come up with a different
name
so just to kind of have a different
title not always the same one
so um well we have named it breakdown
unexpected studies
um if you guys were following my
sellers just clubs twitch channel on
sunday i did start some domin i did show
some domination
uh positions where the knight was
dominating the bishop so i kind of have
that idea in mind but then there are a
couple of interesting studies
especially one of them is very awesome
that i kept towards the end so i really
hope to see all of you guys
watch until the end without further ado
let us get started so the first position
that i have
here set up is a study by
perrone it's a proper name hi
thanks for joining so
in this position it is white to move and
you're trying to figure out a way
for white to win obviously uh what you
guys may already know that
um in
[Music]
well knight end games are supposedly
very similar to king and pawn and games
so if the knight end game
is sorry if the king of pawn end game
would be winning then
probably the night end game should be
winning as well
but in a lot of situations it is very
difficult especially if the opponent's
king is close
to to the ponds or in front of the pawns
then
there's usually the opportunity to
sacrifice the knight for the pawn or
pawns and then you know it should be a
draw but in this case we have pawns
really far away one on each edge of the
board
so it may not be so easy
uh to stop those spawns um
and obviously it will not be easy
because that's the point we're trying to
we're trying to find the win in this
position and um
i wonder if any of you has an idea of
what should happen here with white and i
have this similar
similar position by the same author with
the 19b8 so it's going to be a little
bit different but basically what you
have to try to do
is uh finding a way to dominate blacks
knight because obviously blacks knight
is going to try to stop
the h pawn the a pawn is going to be
captured by black's king
clearly there's no simple way to to
defend it and even if you
manage to defend it with knight c7 after
chasing black's knight away from e6
there still will be king b6 and um
you probably won't be able to hold on to
that pawn so that point is going to fall
but the question is will you be able to
win with white with the h
pawn and the answer is yes um
and actually it does matter what white
plays in this position you cannot attack
this knight
anyhow there's just one way that wins it
the two natural moves that come to mind
are king d7 and king to d7 both of these
moves
are possible you just need to figure out
which one is actually the one that will
uh will help you win and the correct
move is king to e7
what happens after king d7 uh probably
black is going to play a move like
knight g5
and then obviously you have to try to
defend your pawn as actually that knight
is hanging too so you have to play
knight c7
and now they will try to go for the pawn
you have to push
and then as i was mentioning to you
previously king to b6
this way the king keeps both the pawn
and the knight attacked
and there isn't so much you can do
hi everyone thank you for joining
joining
yes yes there um
there are lots of uh there are lots of
beautiful uh
studies out there and domination is
certainly a beautiful
theme i think so i did i did choose
a bunch of domination studies
for today's um for today's video so here
the problem is that
like if you try to go for example king
here and then supposedly
going there to play a7 obviously we
won't let that happen
your knight is stuck to protect the pawn
and then you don't have sufficient time
to come the other way around to chase
the king
because obviously he will play king b6
so there's no way for white to continue
progressing this position
but what's the difference now with king
e7 instead well rocking e7 you're
attacking the knight and now they kind
of have two
uh two moves that that make more sense
we'll we will try other moves as well
but
knight d4 and uh knight f4 other ones
that seem to make the most
sense for black knight g5 is an option
as well but knight g5
seems to allow h4 to be played and black
is certainly trying to keep white from
pushing that pawn
forward too much so with either one of
these moves at uh
knight d4 or knight f4 that h pawn is
stopped because their
checkpoint ideas therefore stopping
weight from pushing it
so we'll first start with knight f4 um
controlling the h3 square and also once
again there's knight g6 if you push and
let's not forget this knight is hanging
so
uh white does need to play king c7 and
the point is that now if uh if black
plays
king b6 then we will have 96 trying to
trade the knight and then no matter how
you you do
things now this knight is going to be
placed in c5 defending the pawn from
behind it which is a very typical theme
in uh knight end games
or you know knight and pawn versus king
type of ideas he has to stay there he
cannot move anywhere and then
you should be able to win by supporting
the h1 with your king
um so for example if you just pretend
you're just sitting and waiting while
playing f6
and then you can keep sitting and
waiting we push
a typical way for for someone
to stop red upon with the knight is to
kind of oops
this maneuvering i'm not even sure how
to
call this as like a square that is
formed so then i just kind of
um just moves around in circles based on
how you attack it but the point is if
white manages to win blacks knight then
obviously they will win on the other
side of the board
right so if we go here and he goes
knight f3 right
uh we are going to go king of four for
example right attacking the knight
and if you go knight here we are
attacking the knight you move it away
and then we push h4 because this is not
the situation where black can sacrifice
the knight for the pawn
and that's usually you know that's
basically the pattern that will
happen throughout all right
going back to this position if instead
of
king b6 black would try knight here in
order to stop
the pawn from pushing forward king f6
you can still do the same thing but
uh now 96 you will take the pawn right
it makes total sense because now there's
no way
since white brought the king here uh but
now what we notice is the king and the
knight together
will kind of dominate black's knight so
we'll play king of five
and you bring in the king right king b5
because you're trying to kind of you
know bring the king knight to four
offering a you can check if you want to
and now a very important move of
domination you have to figure out where
this knight may go but you also have to
keep
black skin from entering in front of the
pawn right so king e6
is the correct move here you have to
trust me on that
and then the knight restricts the square
which
you know black's knight could stop the h
pawn and then we slowly march so pretend
you go here king c4 king c5 we slowly
march the h
pawn and there will be no simple way for
black to stop that one say you play a
move like this
king of five check
what do we play now
does anyone have any ideas
actually i i might have gone wrong wait
a second actually i think i can i don't
need king of five i think i can just
play h5 i made a mistake i don't need
king f5
i can just push h5 yeah
what am i saying uh followed by
you know king of five the next move and
black's king is way too far from the
pawn
yeah in that position also it was
possible after knight g4
knight g4 king f5 here king e5 but then
he can come right back so you haven't
even
you haven't actually progressed the
position that's why h5 is good whenever
you can push the pawn you push it
forward and then you bring in the king
to chase the knight away so this is
basically what's happening after knight
f4
in case of knight d4 with a similar idea
but you're also
you know keeping the knight close enough
that you can
i i guess give some checks not not so
important
knight f3 h3 and now kim b6
we have a similar uh you know pattern
with white
we are going to restrict or dominate
black's knight we're keeping those
squares
away from it you have to take another
king
marches here and
a beautiful move in this position i
wonder if any of you can find it
so gorgeous because
um after this move black will not have a
way to stop the h pawn anymore
this is i believe a very nice move for
white
that helps white win the game
so the correct move is knight to d4
simply hanging the knight but the point
is that after knight takes
and h4 black does not have any single
way of
stopping that pawn because this king in
f6 is perfectly placed and it takes you
quite some moves to give a check
so say you go knight t2 we push h5 you
attack the pawn we push h6 you give one
check
and now the correct move i mean i guess
there are
more moves but you kind of go in a
diagonal from the night that way it
takes
um three moves for the knight to give a
check
during which time white will be able to
to
to promote the pawn so very beautiful i
think
move knight to d4 this kind of shows
clear domination where
um you know you're just sacrificing the
night they take but the king
simply restricts black's knight and
there's nothing
nothing to do some of you have gotten
the move right
good job on that all right moving on
to the next position i think this is
this was i hope you guys
like this this kind of pattern like uh
in night 10 games
usually you see domination knight versus
bishop that is a typical
type of idea that you see that is
something that i have shown as i said in
my twitch
stream a few days back but um
but this is night domination and king
dominating at night which
you see more rarely in my opinion you
also see a pawn dominating the knights
typically when
there is uh like in the open in a lot of
openings you would see that when there's
a knight
being developed in c6 for example and
someone plays c3
to restrict the knight from going
forward but here
i find that to be quite nice
now this position is also by the same
author
and okay someone had a question about
the previous one so i feel like
i should go back and discuss it
so in this position if you were gonna go
knight g5
the reason this move would not be so
good is because black would get his
knight
on a good path so he would go knight h4
and now it's not easy for you to chase
it away
from the pawn because now i i can go
knight g2
and and the knight is going to be able
to stop the pawn and
so for example you you cannot sacrifice
it anymore because obviously they take
and they stopped each pawn
so when you go to the side he brings in
the king and if you attack
he's gonna go knight g2 and you don't
really have a simple way to trade this
knight and even if you manage to
during that time black is going to be
able to bring in the king
closer to being in front of the h pawn
and then um the king and pawn end game
will be a draw because that is an h pawn
which
i hope all of you are familiar with and
that's supposed to be a draw so that's
why
knight g5 would not work but knight d4
was the correct move
keeping this knight at the distance from
the h pawn and there's no way for black
to stop it
anymore so the next position is
basically
very similar to the first one just the
position of white
knight is now in b8 instead of a8 which
makes it kind of obvious that white is
going to lose the a pawn
considering that now the knight is
attacked and you have to move it you
don't have
any way to protect at night no way so
i wonder if any of you have an idea on
how you can try to win this position
with white what would be the plan
i i think i've already i've already
described that fits
so i really hope it was clear enough
what i have mentioned
yeah the h pawn cannot push because the
knight will be sacrificed for it
so you wouldn't have the opportunity to
do anything because the king would make
it in front
oh wait maybe you have a point
if knight h4 in this case you're saying
well then there's this germination of
course king to g5 the knight cannot go
forward this knight stops him
from going there you have to go knight
c2 sorry knight g2 and now the knight
dominates
this night once again thanks for
pointing that out i think
this will make it kind of clear how the
king restricts the knight and now
black's knight is trapped
okay and then these are white's next two
moves
and uh it will be game over so
yeah knight d4 is the correct move
and that's where you kind of had to take
and you couldn't go to h4
okay so i made that clear that's good to
to here we have this position now and it
is y to move
so what do we think about this position
well
we're kind of forced to make the first
move i think um
we have knight c6 or knight d7 one of
them you know it's good the other one
not so i guess you could attack the
knight too but
there would be an ig5 check after which
the knight should be able to stop the h
pawn
so knight c6 is the correct move indeed
in this position
uh and black is going to take the pawn
obviously and now h4
and
as i said this kind of ideas do not
quite work because of the king g5
if you keep attacking the knight this is
not the same as the previous position
it takes quite way too many moves to try
to
dominate this knight it's not really
going to work then i can jump around so
much so for example if you play here
they will play king b6 for example and
if you try to bring in the knights
similarly as before right to try to
control those squares and the king would
come this way
for example the king comes to c7 you do
this
and now knight f2 if you want to play
one more move and try to keep the knight
restricted his king comes in
uh and then when you attack the knight
he's gonna go knight g1
and if you go h4 for example the king
just gets in
as i mentioned and black should be able
to hold this position
that's why it is very very important
that you push the pawn immediately
now the king will try to come for
example king b5
and now we are chasing the knight
because you see with the pawn we have
restricted
that strong square for black's knight
and after knight f4 for example
we have this check
and now a similar idea is the previous
position i wonder if any of you can find
it
similar idea where you're deflecting
somehow black's knight
from the control of the h pawn and not
not letting it
promote what do you guys think
so the correct move in this position is
knight 32 yes eric knight to e2
uh knight here would not quite work
because of knight h5
and then the point is that um if you go
king g6 there's knight g3
and you don't quite have a way to get
this knight away from g3
uh to push the pawn and cannot push it
right now and therefore for example if
you do this
you will bring in the king and this does
not work now anymore because the knight
will take it and if you play h5
knight here draw
so now we play knight to e2 the point is
that after capture because you're gonna
never go knight h5 right
the knight will get trapped you have
nowhere to go now
and you have to try to stop the h1 so
this is your only way but now h5
then i can try to come in and knight
threatening knight g5 but then once
again the same idea as
we've seen previously i i felt like
although
these positions are so similar and
they're from the same author
obviously i felt that it's important to
show both because once you get the idea
it's nice to kind of
review it in a way in another position
and i feel that this
kind of reviews it very clearly the king
being placed on a diagonal with one
square in between
itself and the opponent's knight keeps
the knight at the distance
from stopping the past pawn and white is
winning
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining we're currently going over some
interesting studies
um i'm trying to break down some of the
domination ideas
at least in the past two studies i did
do that i hope
um and now even if you bring in the king
age seven obviously and you don't have
uh you know check
checkpoint or check queen later nothing
you have nothing
all right moving on to another position
and
you know it is very hard to talk about
studies and not bring in some king and
pawn end game
kingdom pawn end games are type of end
games that i like to teach the most
because i feel that there are types of
end games that
teach you most of the time how to
calculate they teach you how to think
about
the opponent how to um
to just simply calculate without moving
the pieces
and kind of visualize the board a little
bit better and
you always have to start you know basic
with a little amount of material in my
opinion
and then add more because if you just
start with everything in the beginning
it just
seems to be tough and overwhelm
overwhelming
obviously or not obviously but i believe
many of you who are here probably at the
more advanced level so
um you know you don't need me to remind
you of that
but those are important things that
you have to keep in mind and if you're
struggling with calculation
uh i highly recommend um you know
solving
uh studies and especially starting with
king and poland games you can also try
uh to solve them blindfolded
that helps you even more with pattern
recognition
and and
how to say visualization of the board
so in this kingdom pawn and game
obviously white has a pawn down and
normally if you would
evaluate it um you would think that
white has no chance white may even be
losing this because
the a pawn of black or the a pawns of
black are far away so by the time white
goes to get them
black should be doing great wrong if you
thought that way
definitely wrong that's now how things
[Music]
are going thank you so much guys that's
not how things are going it's not really
that easy
and simple white also has a past pawn
the c pawn is passed as well so you
don't need to only think about
the apon you should think about yours as
well and you should think that you want
to promote it
as well um you have to just find the
right way to
to push the pawn to make sure the
opponent does not have any counterplay
obviously you cannot go for the a
pawn because you cannot go king b5 or
king b6 and going king c5 does not make
sense
at all he is going to simply bring in
his king
and by the time you reach to take those
pawns
this will be basically the end of it
it will probably be a draw as they go
here they take and you guys are
about in the same time to grab the
opponent's pawn so if i just play it out
for example
here here here here
king g2 takes takes and now
king g6 or king h6 black takes this pawn
y takes this one and it is a draw
so i think this this is pretty
straightforward and an idea that you
realize
it cannot work you didn't need to play
it out throughout
like i did uh to understand that it's
not working so great
but what to do so we have two things
that we can do with
white that makes sense one of them is to
move the king
away from the front of the pawn and then
start pushing the c pawn
the other one is start pushing the c
pawn and then figuring out what it is
that they will do
and you also have to figure out where
you place your king now usually
when you're studying simple basic in
component games king pawn versus king
you're learning that it is very
important for the king to be in front of
the pawn
to support its last three pushes
the last three pushes to promotion and
so
ideally you want to place your king
either in b7 or d7 don't you even think
of going
anywhere else okay so
someone is saying that push c4 of course
that's one move that we have to consider
and then there's king b7 or king d7
those are the moves that make sense
if we go king b7 this is the line that
will happen
c5 a3 c6 a2
c7 queen queen and the point is that
with white
what is your chance here he's going to
move the king somewhere
and the best thing that you will do is
maybe some perpetual track
you will not have the opportunity to win
even if you somehow manage to
take this pawn and then trade queens
let's just pretend
then you have to take this a pawn and by
the time your king comes back you may
even be losing
if he manages to take your two two pawns
so you don't have much so definitely i
think it makes sense to you
that white should place their king on d7
not on b7
because on d7 it actually restricts
black skin too and together with the
queen can create some kind of tactical
ideas of mating ideas maybe so now the
question is do you play c4 or do you
looking to d7
i see many of you are thinking d7 but
there were some who are saying
c4 and it's always tricky and you have
to understand if there is a difference
and actually there is a big difference
if you push c4 it's going to be a
mistake because black has sufficient
time
to bring in their king to kind of stop
your pawn so let's just pretend here
here
and now uh you're gonna go king b7 to
try to support that pawn
and so this is basically the best thing
that can happen so even if
you promote first now the king is still
far away cannot support
any kind of idea for you know mate or
anything like that so the game will most
likely end in a draw
if you're thinking about
um starting here here
here instead of um is there a king b7 if
you're singing oh but i can come here
and something no no
no no please don't make this blunder
this would be a blunder
why because the king comes in and when
you take we are dealing with the same
situation just that in this case
probably black is winning because their
king is a little bit better place then
he can try some g5
let's just say go here
oops sorry
um here
you bring in the king here
you bring in the king and now
g4 the point is that
we managed to take this pawn it's not
like you can you cannot take because
king takes g3 and if you go king h4
sim a simple waiting move uh
wins the game you move the king we take
the pawn and then the g pawn wins the
game
the correct move in that position is
king to d7
he's gonna start pushing the pawn
because his king cannot stop the c pawn
anymore
and obviously we are dealing with this
line
both players have promoted to a queen
but now
there's a mate because our king actually
supports the queen so after king f7
and h4 checkmate as you can see
placing the king on the right square
could evenly to mate
even in an end game so i thought this
was kind of nice in a way because
it reminded you that move order matters
the way you are pushing
or moving the king or pushing upon can
be important so you
have to take your time and calculate
everything and also make sure you're
considering the opponent
because the opponent is very very
important
and you wouldn't want them to have some
um
you know tricky uh tricky kind of uh
ways my next position is
the following and it's a study by paula
seck
and i think this is really really
awesome i
really think this end game is this
endgame study is really awesome
because the position is so blockaded and
and white has an extra knight but you
need to come up with a lot of
maneuvering ideas in order
to be able to win if there were more
pieces on the board
and it would be some kind of kappa
blanca style position
you probably would think of domination
on the a file somehow or or activity
you would get active on the a file and
then somehow
you'll be able to do something though
usually there's still a way in kappa
blanca's
games and end games there's still a way
on the other side of the board that they
can
like open up the position and and do
something but in this case
uh there's there's none there's just one
side and there's just one knight so
it is very important to come up with
with an idea on how
white can win this position ideally you
would be thinking that the knight will
have to be sacrificed at some point
for a pawn but then you realize on
whichever pawn you sacrifice the knight
he's going to capture back and then you
won't be able to win with that past pawn
that you're creating because
their king is close enough is in the box
whereas your king is
not really able to support the past pawn
and because you have no entrance
so this is really really nice um
really a really really nice position
so you have to come up with a plan in
order to be able to know what you're
gonna do so someone is seeing
you're bringing the knight to a4 okay
and after that what do you do i will
keep my king
in c6 to keep my c5 pawn protected
king g2 and knight to a4 yeah that's
that's a great idea but what do you do
when
my king will will stay and keep the pawn
protected
you have to figure out which pawn you
want to win
the nine needs to make a big trip around
the board and get to h4
oh that's a nice idea too
[Music]
once the night gets there if they take
it your king will come right back or
it depends where it is you will take
that night and they will have
you will have g5 pawn push takes and
then the king of pawn and game will be
winning indeed
knight to h4 how do we get the knight to
h4 that's the idea so their step
this is a step by step uh end game
yeah this is a step-by-step end game so
i think there are a few steps that you
have to
i don't think i know there are a few
steps you have to
uh get ready in order to be able to get
those um
to get that going and even after that
what do you do after that
so let's see so obviously first move is
king g2 so you're moving the king away
in order to free that square and then
you need to bring the knight
right to h3 and then you're coming right
back to bring it to a4
that's what you guys said right because
you cannot bring it to h4 directly
there's no way to get the knight there
considering the way
white spawns together with black spawns
are located you don't have a way to get
it to h4 if you could that would be
great
okay so you need to bring them
the jeep
the king over to the queen side what are
you going to do if you bring the king
over to the
queen side it's not like you'll be able
to um
to win anything because as i said even
if you sacrifice the knight for one pawn
they will recapture and then their king
will be able to stop your past pawn
and your own king will not have the way
to enter the only way you can
enter is if you place your knight in h4
and they take that way for sure
i will see how so anyways black just
sits and waits
then knight c1 he sits and waits 92
sits and waits knight g1 knight h3 so we
did this
so far he continues to sit and wait
because what to do
um he's not wait
wait why is he sitting there i think the
my move is is wrong my move is wrong he
cannot sit there if he's it's
he sits in in e6 i'm so sorry why did i
put it there i don't know he sits in e6
if he sits in c6 obviously we take and
then
if they capture back then we start pawn
margin we're winning yeah
definitely definitely i'm so sorry i put
the wrong move so he doesn't go to c6 he
sits
around here he sits on e6 right just to
make it very clear
and then um
knight f2 and then back king to d6
right so it's pretty it's pretty simple
to understand
that you cannot take that pawn
all right now we continue knight d1 king
c6
knight b2 king d6 he just sits right
he sits close by to those pawns because
that he realizes is what you want to
attack so knight a 4 king c6
all right so we brought the knight to
that point now what to do
how do we bring it to h4 as you guys
want
get the knight to b6 if you go with the
knight to b6 i'll capture it so
obviously that doesn't quite work
but uh but you can't get it to b6 if
you're making
making a waiting move right if you're
making a move the king exactly
if it's saying it right other people are
saying it right too
you just move the king somewhere
wherever you want
and then he has to move his king
somewhere to keep the pawn protected
indeed and now you can get the knight to
b6 okay that makes total sense
all good now he's just gonna sit and
wait and he will try not to allow your
knight to jump
wherever it is that you want to jump
okay now what do we do next
the knight is in basics
how do we bring the knight further that
is the important idea
that is something you want to get
so you have to bring the knight through
c7
so he's going here
king e6 and now knight c7 check
in d7 not to let the knight jump around
somewhere else
now the knight comes back to b5
no you you cannot because um you know
with the 19th d5 you cannot really
sacrifice in f4 or something here for
example after king e6 if you sacrifice
he will just take with the e pawn that
way you're having no entrances with your
own king he just sits around that pawn
and there's no way to win so clearly
he needs to bring the knight to b5 king
c6 what is our next stage of the plan
this this is like i would say this is
like a stage
stage by stage type of position that you
have to to understand and keep in mind
you bring the king to b2 someone is
saying okay what's the point
in order to be able to play knight h3
yes because the knight is stuck right
now on b5
you don't really have an easy way to get
it out of there so you need to bring in
the king sir when you play knight
a3 in case they capture it you can
recapture with the oops with the king
and then the king can enter and then
also b4
and uh transposed to a winning king
component game basically
so king
king d2
now there was some small triangulation
really doesn't matter so much
that's how the author gives the solution
but it's still like pretty pretty nice i
think king c6
knight c2 so now we're bringing the
knight as you guys said to h4
now he's rushing very fast on the other
side of the board
because he does not want the knight to
be there he wants to be able to take it
but white still plays this and despite
the fact that black has managed to bring
the king to f6 and have it close enough
in case of
some knight sacrifice to have the king
close enough to actually you know attack
those pawns
now we finally go knight to h4 the point
is if they take
we bring in the king as i told you
previously oops
the king makes it in that direction and
at some point black will be in zugsvang
white will be able to win the pawn and
therefore after that the game for
example
if you just sit and wait
right pretty simple and then we take the
pawn like just
take the pawn you move somewhere that
will push g5
and if you take obviously the king wins
the game
if you don't think and you pretend like
you sit there's still a capture there
king g4 and then the king oops see what
did i do
i'm not sure what they did i apologize
what have i done all right
the king will take and then win those
pawns
and if the king just sits there put
here here here and the king marches to
take those pawns
some people are saying to play negative
seven let's see
let's see what we do now
so he cannot take i think we made it
kind of clear that he cannot take
and the other one like sitting with the
king doesn't work oh pushing the pawn i
think this is something i didn't show
for example and trying to enter with the
king is not going to be sufficient once
again because you cannot really enter
here that's the point
because you have to go back and then
once we take it you go back
and then basically the same thing you
cannot find
any way nowhere with black to stop
then yes it is less than 50 moves we are
moved 29.
so we have we still have chances to win
and also we traded material
so it's not really like it doesn't
matter that is 50 moves
there's no 50 move rule but yeah in some
situations you know i actually had the
game once i remember
i guess the low ready player and the
bad thing about it is that you know i
finally was able to get into a position
where i was winning
but i reached 50 moves that he claimed
to draw i mean after i played for like
two hours
trying to get into the position that i
felt i had some chances he finally
messed up but then
it was too late for me to actually do
something so the king just sits and
waits and now we do 95 i believe someone
said that
king age seven and now if you realize
black skin is stuck and
he doesn't have palm pushes his king is
stuck to protect h6 so if we make
any kind of waiting move like this one
he has to go back we take the pawn after
which it's a much
simple process because like let's just
be like here
you just bring in the knight you try to
take some of the other pawns now you
have this past pawn so
black skin has to stay in the box of it
to stop it and then white is gonna be
able to win
so this was that study it's kind of
crazy i think that from here
you can imagine you have a winning
chance yes you have it you just need to
make sure you take your chances
when they're given to you because you
don't know
what life has in has planned for you you
never know
all right moving on to the next position
and this is kind of a nice one as well
i hope you guys liked my my night
manoeuvring thing
and this position it is white to move
i'm curious how do you guys evaluate
this position if you think white can win
and obviously you're going to tell me
yes
uh
how often it happened to a master level
and did they execute it correctly
uh it's more rare that you get such a
blockaded position and you have to just
maneuver it around
um to get to win like that exactly as
that position was is more rare but it
does happen at times and usually
people execute it correctly especially
like at
like grand masters they usually this is
the way they end up winning you know by
moving the pieces around a lot at some
point their opponent makes a mistake and
then
uh in these types of positions a lot of
top i'm
not just talk but but grandmasters
usually have
a very good sense of what they need to
do in a position and i know that they
can
they usually find a way to win
so this in your calculation is a draw
so in this position white has some nice
ideas
um considering the black's king is
really
kind of restricted here it's really
restricted here
and it kind of stays on a mate that is
something very important for white
to take note of uh because they if they
don't take a note of this
they cannot win because those pawns are
about to be traded so white will not
uh be able to get an additional queen or
whatever piece in order to try to win
and if that pawn is gone you may think
that's it done it's a draw but no
really it's not really like that
the first move in this position is
bishop to g3
king h1
black could i play king g1 2 but then
there's this check
and then we take that's the point and
now the bishop protects and then with
knight and bishop
white is able to win they will first win
the d pawn and then knight and bishop i
hope everyone
is familiar how to win that i should go
over
he had to go king to h1 to avoid the
check
and allowing white to win that pawn and
now knight to e2
so basically if you try something like
this
then he's going to escape so you don't
need to tell
someone it's kind of like in real life
you know if
you tell someone you like them and they
don't like you
uh then you messed up your chance maybe
you can wait
i don't know i'm just saying but anyways
here you can wait a little bit longer
and let's see what's happening so the
king stays on mate
now it's completely restricted but
you're giving black the opportunity to
take your pawn
if they don't take the pawn this idea
will be kind of simple
play king h3 bishop f2 knight g3 mate
so that is basically what you're trying
to do with white
okay so 92 someone said knight h3 knight
x3 can work too but
usually you don't want to do this uh you
have to
if you guys are familiar with the mate
knight and bishop versus king
then you would know how the knight kind
of follows the w right it usually goes
from second to fourth rank
it doesn't really get from first to
third or fourth to third or something
like that it usually goes like that to
make like an
m or a w when you do this the problem is
that you
blockade your king you're blocking the
king and the king has to go to each tree
if the king cannot go there you don't
have a mate he's going to take your pawn
and you don't have a
mate so that's basically what what is
happening in this
in this situation between 92 is very
important because you're keeping that
option open
then the king goes to uh sorry the
bishop goes to f2 knight to g3
so he's gonna take king h3 and now
obviously you cannot just see
like that because we have a very simple
thread
so bishop h2 in case uh
in this position black is considering
say bishop c7
you're going to get mated even easier by
playing like that bishop h2 followed by
knight g3
and there's nothing that you can do
bishop a7 to stop that restriction
and now bishop h2
white is definitely trying to mate with
knight g3 picking the pawn would not
make sense
sub bishop h2
bishop f2 to keep the mate under control
but now black
is running out of more so black will be
running but almost here
after bishop takes d6 um you need to sit
and wait basically
and uh because if you go here for
example there's bishop c5
we block he did that passport now the
king um
keeps white's king keeps likes being
restricted if you move the bishop now
there's 93 m8 if you don't know
which of you lose it you don't have a
way to keep this
but it takes c7 someone is saying they
take c7 after
here after king h1 he takes c7 knot
that's not so strong because he takes
and then he's going to trade his bishop
for one of your minor pieces
if he does that then it's a big problem
because you won't be able to win
peace or whatever piece versus deep one
you won't be able to win unless you get
lucky that your phone doesn't know how
to play and will promote something weird
and will
put themselves in a corner i mean we
will will so many ideas have to happen
from the other side for you to have a
chance so no
and now bishop h2 so we're starting
knight g3 we're back to the line
pitch of c2 and this is the final moment
where you have to take your time
it's kind of like the previous one where
you had to step by step think about how
that knight was gonna jump around and
get to the place that you wanted
in this case it's similar too
so um but but we still get to win some
material so
so bishop takes d6 you need to sit and
wait with the bishop
so pretend you go super far away so i
don't have a way to
to keep restricted and bishop h2
threatening mate once again
so i did take a pawn in the process the
bishop goes back
and now it's a very nice and cute move
nice and cute and that move this bishop
to g1 the point is that you're tracing
the bishop away
but you're also threatening knight g3
and if black moves
if obviously if black takes us knight g3
m8 but if black goes bishop
e1 for example now we move the bishop
away
and this one is stuck it has no moves
the king is stuck so black has to move
this pawn and they will not play g6 to
give it up they'll play d5
and now you go bishop g4 you have
blockaded that pawn
and now you're giving black the move and
he has no good move the bishop has to
move
knight's g3 checkmate the the king
cannot move
so it's kind of done deal
in case of bishop c5 for example in this
position and then
black with plane not d5 but d6
you're not worried about it you don't
need to take the pawn you can just go
back
you want to keep it a little bit longer
to make sure he doesn't get to stalemate
himself you have to see
here here however and now he doesn't
have a good location to sacrifice his
bishop
for it not to be a loss he does not have
a stalemate here so it's kind of game
over
so saying king g1 instead of knight h3
check
i'm not even sure when you're king g1
knight h3 check i think you typed it
wrong
there's no there's no check omar
oh and d67 i thought i did say that that
no
do you think c7 bishop takes c7 you
don't have a check
so you don't have a check the way the
things went you never let
black move the king from h1 it was
always an h1
and that's why maybe you're talking
about this other line
that kj193 check so here maybe you want
it to take so i guess that wins too
here and if he takes you go knight
knight h3
i can take the bishop maybe here is what
you meant here is the possibility too
it's winning goodie and the last
position that i have for you guys for
today
is the following one and it is why to
move
i wonder what do you guys think about
this position
and it is way to move
material is equal but white seems to
have a slightly safer king and the pawn
in c7 could be a huge help for white
so in this position black is starting to
take the pawn in
in c7 we have opposite color bishops
which can be helpful
uh for the attack but it can also be a
problem
is there not we can try to find wait
bishop and knight in game
whatever check you give black and try to
take your pawn in c7
queen f7 is an option if you want to
trade and going into a
bishop engine but this will not work
because after takes takes
they take the pawn and now you think you
he has no way to stop
the huge pawn with the bishop but he
actually does here here
here here here and the bishop stops
the h1 and there's nothing you can do
about it
sun king b6 king b6 is a nice idea but
you're not really
stopping much and check you i can at
least have a perpetual track
or if not i think you can take that pawn
next it depends what you do but i
certainly have at least a perpetual
check
any other ideas and this is beautiful
because it's kind of like domination in
a way
not really domination but more like
it shows you that material does not
matter it doesn't matter how much
material you give up
it measures how much you have on the
board and if it's a good enough one that
you actually have serious threats
because if that is the case you can
sacrifice something and then with the
extra material that you have
you should be able to win
now can you change the queen
queen you trade i just take the pawn
we need two
i think i still think the pawn maybe i
take it with the queen so that i can
take it with check
the other case i took it with the king
because i was in check
queen to f7 queen to f7 um queen takes
f7
bishop takes f7 takes and now right
i just show that line so i'm not sure
maybe you join in later
but yeah so the correct move a beautiful
move in this position for white is
and i kind of made it on purpose to
finish with this position because it is
a queen sacrifice
it is queen to e8 this is an amazing
gorgeousness
gorgeousness i don't know anything you
want to say move i think
because it's a track queen you don't
have a place to move the king to keep
the queen protected so you have to take
and the crazy thing is that in this
position despite having a queen down
white is winning after king b6 the king
b6 were threatening bishop here check
king d7 bishop c6 winning the queen and
then we promoted win
and crazy enough um black does not have
the right kind of checks
to uh to stop the situation so the best
thing that they can do is probably could
be five
if you guys find any other moves please
do let me know
but uh i i looked a little bit more and
i didn't quite see
any way for black to stop the bishop b7
and promotion
that was the first move you're
considering but you didn't find a win
that's okay
queen of fight queen
and the point is now the king cannot do
anything cannot be moved because bishop
c6 and then
we're starting that so the best one for
black is to probably give up
the queen back right back imagine that
you have to give the queen back
now you take this pawn and you're
thinking aha this is it
i saved it everything is fine but no
you did not save it because now we're
pushing h5
um so you have to calculate of course in
this position you may be tempted to play
bishop e4
thinking ah-ha now i'm locating those
pawns
he won't be able to give me uh to
sacrifice i need to open the bishop
and and white will just march with the h
pawn but it's not related like that
because black can stop that pawn
with the king as well but then also
there's f5
and e4 and then d3 so
basically black can sacrifice all of
those pawns and this is going to be a
draw because
the bishop will be able to restrict both
the d and the h1 from the diagonal
he actually will be able to sacrifice
the bishop for the d pawn
and then his king will make it in the
corner and it will be a draw so that's
something very very important
bishop c3 no no bishop c3 because
anyways they
they can take the pawn so it's not like
you can go from
lost to to wieners black not really like
that
so h5 and the point is there's nobody in
the box of the pawn and this bishop is
stuck in a a1 it cannot do
anything oops cannot do anything so d3
bishop e4 f5
and now you don't need to you don't need
to panic
you can just pretend like you didn't see
that your bishop was attacked and when
they take it to go age seven
followed by queen and there's nothing
the black can do they're really behind
with their own promotion and once white
won
uh and well was able to promote white
will be able to
win this game
how did you guys feel about these end
games studies
did you guys like them i hope you did
this is all i have for today uh
i hope you had quite a lot bishop c3
bishop c3 earlier yes i did mention that
there's no possibility to do that
instead of this to play bishop c3 he's
not going to do anything he'll play h6
i'm glad you guys like them
c3 for black kind of never works it
everything was
forced and uh there was no way so we can
take it from the beginning again so
there was check queen you had to take
and then king b6
uh we're threatening that bishop c3 here
would not work
because actually i'm not even sure i
give that check
but i could also take
and then when you take back we can give
check here
and bishop c6 check win the queen
followed by promotion
if you go back
thinking oh i promote well let's not
forget your king stays on mate so all i
have to do is bishop g6 or bishop
f5 bishop g6 is probably the best and
fastest because i'm also attacking your
pawns so if you promote
i checkmate you have no no more choice
nothing to do to stop that and then here
after king takes b5
into c7 i guess you could try bishop c6
now but you will always fall for this
kind of mating ideas because white is
definitely very serious
i'm trying to win so that didn't work
and then um there was no other point i
think
maybe this was the final point where
black would have tried bishop c3 but as
i said
you're a little bit too behind i push h3
and this one wins
favorite study books uh lots of
casparian ones are very good
um gasparian are definitely
some of the best ones and pretty much
any place you can find studies is
is amazing you have to try to solve as
many as you can to help yourself
all right guys i really do appreciate
your time
thank you so much for joining in uh
my you know youtube video with studies
and i hope there were some interesting
domination studies
[Music]
it was great to see all of you here i
hope to see you back be sure to
follow uh and subscribe to
uh san luis chess clubs youtube channel
if you haven't done so yet you will get
notified when we go live
that there's tons of uh important
and and nice videos uh very instructive
ones
uh taught by many top
strong grandmasters and low-rated
players as well
but the the material shared
i think is very important and uh
i really hope you guys do subscribe
uh other than that thank you so much and
i'll see you very soon
either here or on twitch bye bye for now